Let's pretend
this is a safe space.
Sharing intimate secrets
with coworkers can
bond us together
and increase communication
in the workplace.
- Now, who wants to share first?
[gentle acoustic guitar]
- I never admitted this before,
but...
I hate my grandkids.
They just suck.
- One time I hit a deer
with my car...
because I wanted to.
- Look, I am just gonna
say this: I am a cutter,
and that works for me.
- And that's when I realized
I had inadvertently
helped do 9/11.
- Beautiful.
- So, so great. Gorgeous.
Let's all give Ted
a big round of applause
and help him
feel supported.
- Support Ted.
Okay, seems like
everyone has shared.
Except for you, Matt.
Matt, why so shy?
- Oh, yeah, I-I don't
really know if this is for me.
I might just go for a swim.
- Come on, Matt.
We've all shared
with each other,
except for you.
Just tell us something simple.
Be confident.
Like, how did you lose
your virginity?
- Oh. Uh...
Okay.
Well, I was in college,
and it was Halloween night,
and we were watching a movie.
- Spooky. What movie?
- I'd rather not say.
both: Come on, come on.
- It was "Hocus Pocus."
- Excellent film.
- Anyway, I got distracted
by the movie,
and it lasted
way too long,
and that's
the end of that story.
- No, no, no, no.
It's not, Matt.
We gotta go
way, way deeper.
[tribal flute trills]
[deep voice] Way deeper.
♪ ♪
- I fully trust you
with my heart and mind
to close-shave me
with a straight-edge razor.
- I accept and honor
your trust
and wish you
the very best of luck.
- Well, look who's here.
[knife slashes]
- Ow, my face.
- Oh, sorry, Cliff,
but you moved.
- Didn't think
you were the trust-shave,
team-building type.
- Oh, so you were
thinking about me.
Now I have a personal tidbit
to put about you in
my Excel spreadsheet:
"Thinks about Jake... A lot."
- And I have something to put
about you in my Google Doc:
"Suffers from narcissistic
personality disorder."
Wanna get out of here?
- Fine. Twist my arm.
- Jake? [gasps]
[startling music]
I fully trust you
with my heart and mind.
- And then Bette Midler
sang a Broadway rendition
of "I Put a Spell on You,"
and then I, uh--
- Give it to us, Matt.
- Share, Matt.
- I camed.
[applause]
- Good work, Matt.
Good work.
- Give Matt a hug.
Show him some support.
- Everybody touch his body.
Wrap your arms around his neck
and love him.
[swelling orchestral music]